la representante comercial de eeuu que
ayer afirmó que la administración de
widing cree en la protección de la
propiedad intelectual de las vacunas
pero que con el fin de acabar con la
pandemia eeuu apoya a relajar las
medidas de protección de patentes de
estas vacunas contra el coi 19 esto es
importante porque les permitirá a los
países más afectados por la pandemia
como india producir sus propias vacunas
genéricas y responder rápidamente a los
brotes de contagio y no tener que
esperar meses o años por las vacunas la
propuesta de levantar temporalmente
hasta que acabe la pandemia las
protecciones a la propiedad intelectual
de los insumos para producir las vacunas
ya lo había planteado india y sudáfrica
en octubre del año pasado sin embargo
las empresas farmacéuticas habían
frenado la petición argumentando que
esto tendría graves efectos en la
capacidad de producir las vacunas
rápidamente y acabaría además con muchos
empleos en eeuu la representante
comercial de eeuu entonces catherine key
viajará la próxima semana a suiza
ginebra para reunirse con representantes
de otros países europeos y empezar así
el diálogo para lograr el consenso que
es necesario en la organización mundial
del comercio para que se suspendan las
protecciones de las patentes para las
vacunas del coi